bienvenue à la première app innove jeudi
14 avril au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines avait lieu la
première rencontre pour la communauté
open innove un échange intéressant aussi
bien pour les startups tels que ce
qu'allègue que les grands comptes comme
renault ça permet effectivement d'être
d'être plus compétitif de se rendre
compte de la réalité du terrain de
d'avoir accès à un certain nombre
d'outils des gens qui ont l'agilité la
flexibilité et la réactivité face à des
idées qu'il développe et on n'est pas à
l'abri de trouver la pépite sur laquelle
on pourra s'impliquer créer une
dynamique d'ouverture dans l'innovation
c'est le défi du réseau open innove
lancé à l'automne 2015 par la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie de versailles
yvelines en partenariat avec les groupes
rono kpmg fidèles et banque populaire
un réseau qui compte déjà plus de 200
membres ce réseau au pays nov
son objectif c'est de créer une
communauté de l'innovation dans les
yvelines de mettre toutes les structures
et tous les acteurs de l'innovation
ensemble et qu'ils puissent échanger
donc c'est déjà une plateforme numérique
mais c'est aussi des rencontres
comment organiser sur tout le territoire
des yvelines et c'est la première
effectivement à saint quentin en
yvelines après une heure des débats les
130 entreprises présentes pour cette
première appli neuf ont pu profiter
d'une séance de networking pour
découvrir les start up et pme innovantes
du territoire évinois